i usually have a few colds per year
but i haven't had any since the first
lockdown in spring last year
i have been masking and disinfecting
when appropriate is there any downside
to having such a prolonged period of
inactivity for the immune system
is there any downside conceivably there
is some downside but i don't think it
could come
anywhere near the upside that there
clearly is
so you know let's put it this way we can
make an argument
that you will carry immunity away from
these little interactions that you have
which will make you
uh susceptible to them if you encounter
these bugs in the future
so you could kind of make a weak
argument for the benefit
of you know it's like taking pride in
collecting
immunological information in your system
but you're much better off just never
having had these bugs and if you get
them later then you'll pick up the
immunity so
i would say don't question it stay away
from these
capacity for adaptive immunity doesn't
decline
right the the exposure um
the the fact that you might have a
slight head start on something should
you be exposed in a larger dose
will not exist but the capacity to
develop adaptive immunity
does not decline just because your
immune system has spent a year not
mostly being exposed to yeah it wouldn't
be that it will decline a little bit
because you'll be older
um but i would just say you know the
thing that we never
talk about is that all of these uh
diseases that have symptoms have
symptoms because they're doing tissue
damage
and that tissue damage has a cost that
we don't typically
measure and so you know you
you in theory have the capacity to live
to 120 years of age
you won't you won't because you will
have encountered all sorts of things to
damage you along the way and burned up
some of the capacity that you would have
needed to be present
in order to get to 120 and if we turned
the dial in favor of more repair
capacity then you'd probably die much
earlier of cancer so anyway those two
things have been balanced but the basic
point is look
if you can avoid the damage that comes
with being sick and
the downside is that you might get sick
with that thing later
there might be a tiny little extra cost
to being sick with it later on the other
hand
if you get hit by a bus tomorrow then
you weren't sick ahead of time
and you got away with it so anyway i
would say
i think the answer you're looking for is
no it's a slam dunk win
right does it mean that if we analyze
the downside in isolation that it's
zero it's not zero it might be something
but it's going to be tiny relative to
the upside go with it
stay healthy and to the extent that you
can learn the lessons of
2020 and 2021 and figure out how never
to get these
diseases in future uh cold seasons
all the better